[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit hanna
zimmermann und christian sievers
guten abend in allen sie stehen schlange
heute in moskau um abschied zu nehmen
von einem der im westen als held
gefeiert wird als gorbi und zuhause von
denen verachtet die sich die sowjetunion
zurückwünschen michael gorbatschow bekam
kein staatsbegräbnis aber die letzte
ehre von tausenden die es sich nicht
nehmen ließen an seinen sack zu kommen
einer war heute nicht dabei der
russische präsident wladimir putin hatte
terminprobleme wie es offiziell hieß der
satz heute von einem liberalen
russischen polit veteran bleibt im
gedächtnis diese menschen kamen um zu
sagen danke herr gorbatschow sie haben
uns eine chance gegeben aber wir haben
sie vertan für begann mit
bemerkenswerten stimmen aus moskau
es passiere eine katastrophe im land und
jeder mit herz und verstand wisse dass
sagt elena die in den farben der ukraine
gekommen ist um von michael gorbatschow
abschied zu nehmen
dieser verzweifelte politische schrei
diese angst all das wird vorüber ziehen
wie schlechtes wetter und
dann wird gorbatschow die person sein an
die man sich am dankbarsten erinnert
stadt staatsbegräbnis für den letzten
präsidenten der sowjetunion eine
trauerfeier mit ehrengarde überstunden
reißt der strom der die gorbatschow die
letzte ehre erweisen nicht ab
ich kenne diese zeit nur aus erzählungen
meiner eltern aber ich verstehe ganz
klar was für eine bedeutung diese person
für unser land hatte er gab uns die
hoffnung die veränderungen das was uns
jetzt so viel
und am donnerstag
durch
meine besten jahre waren während
gorbatschow
eröffnete die welt er schenkte mir die
freiheit
ist davon etwas geblieben nein alles
wurde zerstört und wird jetzt endgültig
erledigt
derjenige der dafür verantwortlich ist
nahm sich am sarg von gorbatschow etwa
30 sekunden zeit am donnerstag heute
hatte der präsident andere termine als
putin ende februar die ukraine über viel
hat gorbatschow sich öffentlich nicht
mehr geäußert dimitrij muratow
chefredakteur der kreml-kritischen
novaja gaseta und wie gorbatschow
friedensnobelpreisträger stand ihm bis
zuletzt nahm er
war sich sicher dass die zeit
unwiderruflich vorüber war probleme der
weltordnung mit gewalt zu lösen
dass man bis radler und busse aber
zwischen der welt und einer nuklearen
explosion gibt es jetzt keinen mann mehr
namens golden
state muss china bei emilio gorbi als
einziger regierungschef der eu heißt
viktor orban an der westen auch
deutschland schickt seine diplomaten
sagen gorbatschow sah seine
hauptleistung darin dass er den kalten
krieg beendete
doch dann kam der kalte krieg zurück die
heutige führung wolle zurück zur
sowjetzeit meint war die epoche der
anwalt vertritt russlands oppositionelle
von nawal nebel scaramuzza sie alle
wurden von putins regime hinter gitter
gebracht
ich bin nicht immer und in allem
gorbatschows meinung aber ich möchte
festhalten dass die menschen die
gekommen sind um sich von ihm zu
verabschieden überwiegend menschen sind
die gegen putin sind michail gorbatschow
bleibt in russland umstritten doch
diejenigen die wie er an freiheit und
frieden glauben wollen konnten dies
heute öffentlich zeigen eine sehr selten
gewordene gelegenheit dem heutigen
russland mit all seinen repressionen
deutschland wurde heute vertreten durch
den geschäftsführer der botschaft der
bundestag will am mittwoch in berlin an
michael gorbatschow erinnern und damit
in die deutsche politik wo die aktuelle
regierungskoalition ja schluss machen
wollte mit endlosen nachtsitzungen bei
schwierigen themen deshalb ging es heute
vorsichtshalber schon mittags los und
dann wurde eine endlose tages sitzung da
raus und es ist noch nicht ganz
ausgemacht ob auch noch eine endlose
nachtsitzung aus dem ganzen wird wuchtig
und zielgenau und irgendwie auch
bezahlbar sollte das entlastungspaket
werden angesichts der tatsache dass die
preise ja rapide steigen wie das
aussieht wissen wir auch am ende dieses
tages noch nicht und deswegen gehen wir
jetzt live nach berlin zu stark und
hanna banerjee die aufwartet
schackenthal was ist denn los ja die
sitzung geht jetzt bald in die elfte
stunde dass es deutlich länger als sich
die runde eigentlich vorgenommen hatte
sie sitzt noch zusammen man berät noch
und die formel für ein überzeugendes und
bezahlbares entlastungspaket die scheint
offensichtlich schwieriger zu sein als
man dort gedacht hat das ganze hatte
sich heute über den tag hin schon
mehrfach verschoben eigentlich wollte
man um 9 uhr schon zusammen sitzen dann
hat man sich an die gute alte formel
dieser ob dieser ampel erinnert und hat
gesagt lasst uns doch vorher noch einmal
separat beraten und schauen ob wir schon
schritte aufeinander zugehen können
haben sich also die koalitionsparteien
erst mal einzeln beraten dann ging es
erst um viertel nach zwölf los also es
gibt offensichtlich auf dieser langen
liste von entlastungs ideen und
finanzierungsvorschlägen noch einige
differenzen und die räumt man jetzt eben
stück für stück aus und das dauert ein
großes bauwerk hatte der bundeskanzler
ja angekündigt es ist offenbar gerade
von dir hören kein leichtes bauwerk was
kann man denn inhaltlich schon sagen was
auf jeden fall drin sein wird also auf
jeden fall dürfte es entlastungen geben
für rentnerinnen und rentner für
studierende und auch für
sozialhilfeempfänger das hat jetzt die
ampel im vorfeld so oft betont daran
kommt man nicht vorbei aber alles andere
ist eben verhandlungssache und was er
auffällig ist ist dass die runde
wirklich dicht hält man will
offensichtlich erst am ende mit einem
die überzeugenden paket vor die medien
treten und hat vielleicht auch in
erinnerung noch das beim letzten
entlastungspaket ist dann am in der so
viel kritik gegeben hat das ist eben
nicht gut ausgesehen hat das wenn man
auf jeden fall vermeiden und es war ja
vieles im gespräch vor allem eben die
frage wie finanziert man das ganze wird
es bei dem einstelligen
milliarden-betrag bleiben den christian
lindner jetzt als verfügungsmasse im
bundeshaushalt sieht oder muss es mehr
werden da hatten die grünen schon gesagt
das kann ein so kleines paket kann es
nicht sein wie finanziert man das dann
ist es ein nachtragshaushalt ist es die
über gewinn steuer alles umstrittene
maßnahmen und alles umstrittene
finanzierungsvorschläge und es wird
schon spannend werden ob heute abend
noch etwas rauskommt oder ob wir
vielleicht erst morgen erfahren wie es
dann ausgegangen ist ganz kurz noch
total aber morgen dann doch oder oder
ist es auch möglich dass es noch
weitergeht es ist sehr unwahrscheinlich
dass die koalition ohne ein ergebnis aus
diesem wochenende raus geht der nächste
nächste woche geht es irgendwie
verhandlungen über den bundeshaushalt im
bundestag und bis dahin sollten dann
doch die maßnahmen fest stehenden einige
werden wahrscheinlich auch mit dem
bundestag verhandelt werden und dort
abgestimmt werden müssen sagte aber
vielen dank nach berlin
und jetzt zu einem thema das für
aufbruch stehen soll und neuanfang aber
bislang mit abbruch und verzögerung
schlagzeilen macht die neue nasa
mondrakete kommt nicht ins all
jedenfalls nicht wie geplant auch der
zweite startversuch heute in cape
canaveral wurde abgebrochen hier ist
unser usa-korrespondent el mati wissen
seit dem frühesten morgen warteten sie
auf das donnern der rakete auf das
zittern der erde hier mehr und nun
wähler aus münchen ist enttäuscht ihr
vater auch schon ja weil ich wollte
einfach mal live miterleben dass es so
ein monster lifetime möglichkeit den
kindern erzählt ihr werdet vielleicht
erleben das land und da bin ich schon
tot aber
mal schauen ja
um 4 uhr sind wir auf stand für die
firmen familie aus utah ist es schon der
zweite abbruch nach einer zitterpartie
dass hier völlig normal vor dem start
das auch aber irgendwo war der wurm drin
genauer beim einfüllen von rund drei
millionen litern treibstoff gab es ein
leck es ließ sich einfach nicht stopfen
also
scrub zu deutsch wegputzen nennt man den
abbruch besser als eine explosion zu
riskieren dann wären 4,1 milliarden
dollar investitionen verloren
so schön wäre es wohl gewesen wenn es
geklappt hätte die antriebe befördern
rund 2600 tonnen last gen im orion modul
sitzen dann menschenartigen dummies mit
sensoren um die belastung für eine
mission mit weiblichen und männlichen
astronauten zu testen in der umlaufbahn
um den mond soll dessen oberfläche
detailliert vermessen werden
insbesondere stellen an denen eis
vermutet wird mit diesem vereisten
wasser kann man eine ganze menge
anfangen man kann damit zb trinkwasser
herstellen
sauerstoff zum atmen
möglicherweise sogar raketentreibstoffe
oder eben auch dieses wasser benutzen um
baustoffe herzustellen die man am ende
benutzt um infrastruktur auf dem mond
aufzubauen eine basisstation um dann
irgendwann in die tiefe des raums
aufzubrechen auch zum 8
1972 hüpften das letzte mal menschen
über den mond männer jessica mehr aus
dem team der astronauten könnte
vielleicht die erste frau auf dem mond
sein sie trainiert dafür im johnson
space center in houston
es ist unglaublich aufregend der
forscherdrang ist teil der menschlichen
natur mit tiefgreifenden einfluss auf
die gesellschaft die beim ersten flug
zum mond
was sind da schon ein paar tage oder
wochen verzögerung schließlich geht es
auch um die sicherheit der menschen die
nächstes jahr mitfliegen sollen und sie
werden wiederkommen bis die rakete dann
doch noch in den himmel steigt
dann warten auf das zittern der erde wie
immer gerade so schön sagte susanne
freitag ist live für uns in cape
canaveral
hallo susanne wie hoffnungsvoll sind
denn die technikerinnen und techniker
vor ort dass es in den nächsten tagen
noch klappt
also die nasa gibt gerade zurzeit noch
eine pressekonferenz und sie hat schon
angekündigt dass das wohl nichts wird in
den nächsten tagen der start wird
definitiv wohl auf oktober verschoben
weil die wahrscheinlichkeit dann größer
ist dass man diese rakete wirklich
startklar macht sozusagen
hoffnungsvoll sind sie auf jeden fall
die haben auch gesagt wir hätten diese
rakete nicht auf die startrampe gefahren
wenn wir nicht schon hoffnungsvoll
gewesen wären aber dass das jetzt so
passiert ist normal das haben wir gerade
im beitrag auch schon gehört nasa chef
bill nelson ist selber astronaut war
mehrmals im alt und hat noch mal von
seiner mission erzählt auf dem
spaceshuttle die ist viermal verschoben
worden und beim fünften mal hat es dann
reibungslos geklappt und auch in diesem
fall darf man ja nicht vergessen es ist
ein jungfernflug es ist ein unbemannter
testflug aber irgendwann sollen in
dieser orion-kapsel astronauten sitzen
und da ist es natürlich besser wenn man
alles gecheckt hat wenn es wirklich
keine fehler gibt und wenn man weiß bei
diesem ersten mal wo niemand drin sitzt
hat man alles gut in den griff bekommen
als wenn man irgendwelche risiken
eingeht die außerdem noch mit wirklich
extrem hohen finanziellen konsequenzen
verbunden wären
oktober wahrscheinlich oktober
wahrscheinlich sparen der analyse ganz
herzlichen dank live aus cape canaveral
wo es auch ein traumstrand gibt wie wir
sehen die sonne freitag vielen dank und
weitere wichtige nachrichten hast jetzt
du hier im blick und da schauen wir
zuerst auf die ostsee pipeline nord
stream 1 durch die weiterhin kein gas
fließt grund sei ein ölleck erklärte
gazprom gestern die bundesnetzagentur
bezweifelt dass allerdings die
behaupteten mängel seien technisch kein
grund für die einstellung des betriebs
erklärte die behörde ähnlich äußerte
sich auch der hersteller der betroffenen
turbine siemens energy laut
bundesnetzagentur ist die
versorgungssicherheit in deutschland
trotz des stopps gewährleistet die
gasspeicher seien zu 84,5 prozent
gefüllt
das von russland besetzte ukrainische
atomkraftwerk sapori china ist heute
erneut vom netz getrennt das erklärte
die internationale atomenergiebehörde
allerdings würde weiterhin strom über
eine reserve leitung fließen ein reaktor
sei noch in betrieb und produzierte
strom für die kühlung und andere
wichtige sicherheitsfunktionen auch
heute wurde wieder beschuss auf die
anlage gemeldet die russische
regionalverwaltung machte dafür die
ukraine verantwortlich
inmitten der spannungen zwischen taiwan
und china wollen die usa der
taiwanesischen regierung waffen im wert
von über einer milliarde euro verkaufen
darunter ein radar warnsystem für die
luftabwehr und schiffs abwehrraketen es
werde bereitgestellt was notwendig sei
damit taiwan seine fähigkeit zur
selbstverteidigung aufrechterhalten
könne hieß es aus dem weißen haus der
sprecher der chinesischen botschaft in
washington warnte der schritt würde die
stabilität in der region gefährden
bei neuen überflutungen in pakistan
sollen mindestens 50 menschen ums leben
gekommen sein damit steigt die zahl der
toten auf fast 1300
seit juni kämpft das land mit
ungewöhnlich starken monsun-regenfällen
und in der folge mit verheerenden
überschwemmungen ein drittel des landes
steht unter wasser millionen menschen
sind auf der flucht
und wenn sie den flutopfern helfen
wollen können sie das über das
aktionsbündnis katastrophenhilfe
bahn.de 65 104 106 100 104 106 100
stichwort zdf nothilfe pakistan
zu den lottozahlen an diesem samstag die
lauten
36 36 39
43 49 superzahl 2 alle angaben wie immer
ohne gewähr
wird noch der blick auf die
wetteraussichten morgen eine meist
freundliche mischung aus sonne und
wolken vereinzelt auch mal ein schauer
vor allem im bergland höchstwerte 21 bis
29 grad die weiteren aussichten am
montag viel sonne bei 21 bis 31 grad ab
dienstag wieder zunehmend patrick aber
oft noch sommerlich warm so und jetzt
können sie erleben wie das aussieht wenn
einer moderatorin ihrem studiogast
gerade mal bis zum knie geht oder so
sorry donia dirk nowitzki gleich im
aktuellen sportstudio und wir schauen
natürlich zu auf jeden fall und ihnen
jetzt noch einen schönen abend
[Musik]